the next awards are for cinematography
that's a fancy word for cameramen but
they're pretty fancy people that takes
years to learn the art which is why you
seldom see a cameraman under 50 they
look even older it's because of the
first ones on the set in the morning and
the last to leave the bar at night to
present the cinematography award here is
a lady to whom many a lens is made love
Kim Novak she's accompanied by the
handsome English actor who recently
swept you to the altar
mr. and mrs. Richard Johnson
now that mr. Hope has explained who
cinematographers are shall we read the
nominations right nominated for the best
achievement in cinematography of a
black-and-white picture are loyal rigs
for in arms way Burnett Guffey for King
rat Conrad Hall for Marty
Robert Burke's for a patch of bloom
Ernest Lazlo by ship of fools are you
open it darling the winner is
Ernest Laszlo for ship of fools
I had a wonderful journey on this ship
thank you I'm very grateful
for the best achievement in
cinematography of a colored picture the
nominees are
Leon sham Roy the agony and the ecstasy
William C Miller and loyal Griggs for
the greatest story of a tow-ready young
for dr. Zhivago tape McCord for The
Sound of Music and Russell Harlan for
the Great Race you do the honors okay
and the Widder winner is ready young or
dr. Zhivago accepted on behalf of
Frediani English stiva
on behalf of mr. young I want to thank
the Academy for this one Kalon thank you